located in central London is a public  park that remains hidden to even the  locals the medieval style Church of sin  Dunstan in the East was built in around  1100 and has had a long 900 year old  history in 1666 it was rebuilt after  being damaged in the Great Fire of  London then during world war ii a direct  hit during the London Blitz destroyed a  majority of the structure  leaving behind early the north and south  walls and steeple instead of rebuilding  once again the City of London decided to  turn the remains of some Dunston in the  east into the public garden which is  accessible today if you know where to  look  tucked away from the main road the  garden is situated between the Tower of  London and London Bridge  the green Ivy covered walls trees and  flowers offer an enchanting escape from  the city and serve as a reminder of  London's history  you